- (both) OW!
- Candy canes are kind of lame.
- I like candy canes.
- I'm very pro-candy cane.
- I don't like hard things in my mouth.
- I feel like they just taste
old. They taste like the 70s.
- You're gonna give us penis candy.
- Like a curved penis candy cane.
- I hope it's not salmon
or something weird.
- I'm getting earthiness from it.
- Tastes like dirt.
- Frappuccino? Actually,
no. I would say a macchiato.
- Tuna!
- Oh..oh!
- It's bacon! It's (bleep) bacon!
- It tastes like the
blandest bacon I've ever had.
- It tastes like the flavor of gristle.
- Is there pig in this?
- I keep licking it but I don't like it.
- It smells like the beach.
- To me this smells
like an airport hanger.
- (Inaudible)
- It doesn't taste like anything.
- Wait for it.
- Take it out of your mouth.
- I don't want to get my hands sticky.
- Ugh! Whoa!
- This is a spicy one.
- A big, red candy cane
mixed with a jalapeno.
- Is this a sriracha candy cane?
- What kind of evil person did this?
- Okay, whoever made this
definitely is not Asian.
- This is two things that I don't like
teaming up to ruin my day.
- Probably gonna be..
- Broccoli?
- Lime?
- It smells like feet.
- Now I'm starting to get a flavor.
- Yeah, it tastes like vomit to me.
- Spearmint?
- If this is kale I'm
going to smack someone.
- It could be Brussels sprout.
- Is it boogers?
- Are you still on it? Jesus.
- (laughter)
- I'm trying to figure out what it is.
- It's dill.
- Oh.
- Dill pickle.
- Who is coming up with this nightmare?
- I like the whole experience of a pickle.
The crunch, the taste, the flavor.
And this is just a
fraction of the experience.
- Smells like straight up foot.
- (gagging) Yep, I got it.
- Oh my God!
- Ah, spicy!
- Is it pizza? Is it pepperoni?
- You're putting it back in you're mouth!
- I want to know what it is!
- Whoa. Whoa!
- This is wasabi.
- Which one is worse, wasabi or sriracha?
- This one.
- This one is way worse.
- Wasabi is not that bad.
- Wasabi is delicious.
- I think candy canes
should remain as decorations
and they should not be eaten if they
are not flavored like mints.
- I'm really scared to have one now.
- They're fun to look at but
I don't want them in my mouth.
- You're a Scrooge.
- Now candy canes are
just one big dad joke.
- Yeah, my body is like,
" what did you put in me
and why did you do it?"
- That's what..
- Don't say it!